[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to chess
openings explained today I'm gonna be
taking a look at some clutch chess
openings so these of course are the
openings used in the big clutch chest
finals match that just took place
between Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano
karamaneh it was a very exciting match
of course there's a lot of
back-and-forth there were five out of
six decisive games in the final day and
in particular I really wanted to look at
the openings that were played when
Fabiano had the white pieces and of
course we're also gonna take a look at a
couple different openings when Magnus
had the white pieces but in particular
in particular I like focusing on these
three Fabi games because both of the
players were very consistent with their
openings and you can see how they
adapted as the match continued as you
know each players started showing some
new ideas they started coming up with
some new ways to combat those so let's
jump right into it now this first game I
believe was game number seven so this
was the first game of the final day if
I'm recalling correctly so Fabi has the
white pieces he plays this movie for
which of course you probably have seen
before and then Magnus goes for c5 now
we have net f3 Magnus has been playing
knight c6 and Fabi is a big Rasul emo
player with Bishop b5 now there are a
ton of ways that black can respond to
the Russell V mo g6 for example the most
popular movie six d6
just Knight f6 Queen b6 you can play so
so many moves here but Magnus chooses
none of the above and he plays the
slightly strange looking move e5 and now
we have a very very strange-looking
position that could actually be gotten
from a 1.e4 e5
well actually it couldn't really be
gotten unless you get there from a very
strange move order because the night
would be attacking this pawn before this
pawn could launch out to c5 so the idea
of this opening for Magnus there are
kind of a few ideas the main point of
course is the difference in the Royal
apes' is that we have this pawn on c5
instead of c7 so Magnussen's gonna claim
that's like a really useful advantage
you know having this pawn on c5 means
that this d4 square is going to be well
under blacks control for the immediate
future meaning it might be slightly more
difficult for white to play things like
an early D for an early c3 d4 because
black does have this extra pawn
controlling this square the downside to
this is of course you are spending some
time and with this pawn already being on
c5 it really does become clear that this
bishop is going to be more or less the
we kind of problem piece for black in
this case now the c5 square is very
often a square that this Bishop can jump
out to and openings like the Italian or
the slower e4 e5 positions and even
you'll see this Bishop come out to be
four rarely if a knight lands on c3 or
something but with the pawn on c5 none
of those options available to black and
so the the story of this is going to be
of this Bishop also of the time spent
moving this c5 pawn here it is actually
going to give black some minor
difficulties in the center because he
has spent some more time and has not yet
adequately really defended this pawn now
Bishop takes c6 is a playable move right
after the bat and after D takes c6 you
really don't want to capture this pawn
due to these ideas
due to these ideas of Queen d4 attacking
both a knight and the pawn but Bishop
takes c6 is fine and you can play d3 and
this is a position that probably a lot
of Russell Nimoy players would be quite
happy with you know you trade the bishop
off for the night you get the the
fractured pawn structure on the Queen
side for your opponent and you can
continue playing chess
from here instead though Bobby just
castles and now Magnus is still faced
with these awkward difficulties of
developing this bishop and so he brings
this bishop out to d6 solving two
problems at once giving this bishop a
square and also defending the e5 pawn
now of course this looks like a very
very unnatural developing move at at
first glance here this bishop comes out
to be six it's not really looking at any
open diagonals at all it's kind of stuck
by behind these pawns but it is a very
useful piece here and it's important to
understand that in a lot of these efore
a5 positions this bishop gets moved
around quite a bit for example when you
see it come out to c5 very often it is
later followed up with a move like a six
and a bishop dropping back to a7
occasionally even all the way back to b8
or c7 depending on the case
and also in some cases you'll see a Rick
e8 and the bishop dropping back to f8
because really in these openings this
bishop is not quite comfortable being so
so far outside pawn chain so this Bishop
on d6 in black size is just going to be
a temporary miss placement of the bishop
and then eventually that Bishop is going
to get back into a more natural square
but it's serving a very nice temporary
role defending the e5 pawn d3 now for
white is a nice simple developing move
by Fabi now we have Knight G to e7 was
not played this is sorry
generally a common developing square for
the knight and we'll see why black does
end up putting this knight on e7 in the
next game but due to follies move order
black is actually allowed to place the
knight on to f6 here instead and the
fact of the matter is very often when
you play systems like these you just
kind of say okay my bishop goes here my
net goes here behind it on e7 and then I
just develop and castle and play from
there but it's important to look out for
these opportunities early on in the game
because
just via chess understanding it's very
very clear that f6 is a better square
than a seven if we can attain it
so the question kind of arises well PI
does than I'd ever go to e7 and hold
tight on that question we're gonna
really go in depth in that in the second
game I want to look at and now in my
opinion after this night lands on the f6
square Black has more or less nothing to
worry about here
the downside as opposed to come into E 7
is that this pin does kind of gain in
strength a little bit as you know
there's never going to be any f6 to
break this pin and moving the Queen out
of the pin is also going to be a bit
more difficult because now a capture on
e7 fractures the pawns rather than a
capture on a fracture on a capture on f6
fractures this pump fractures the pawns
whereas a capture on e7 would not do so
so excuse me
so Bishop g5 is fabi's choice and this
is the justification for allowing
Knights come to f6 but it comes very
very clear in this game that after
Bishop h4 we see black kick the other
bishop around as well and now black can
just drop this bishop back to e7 and
unfortunately there's just no issues
here for black now he got the bishop
back to a natural square he dealt with
the problem of the e5 pawn by moving
this bishop away he dealt with the pin
by dropping the bishop back he's now
free to think about ideas of d6 35 even
expanding on the Queen side with b5 and
this is just going to be a good version
of efore e5 systems of course many 45
royal apes' players with black will know
that oftentimes this black knight moves
out of the way so the pawn can come out
to c5 and then will even jump right back
on occasion so this is now just a good
version for black having this pawn on c5
is going to be a positional advantage
rather than disadvantage and all those
downsides that we saw coming with it you
know the weakness on e5 the problem of
the bishop well those have been pretty
well solved now by black so that is what
Fabi should have been trying to avoid
and as you can probably see the result
on your screen there
comfortable opening position dirt did
turn out to be a very very nice plane
for Magnus the game continued with c3
still going for these d4 breaks we have
castles by Black Knight BD to buy white
the simple d6 by a black just completing
development now a4 is an attempt to slow
down the East Queen side pawn storms and
now the move Knight h5 comes by black
and this is now just solidly middle
gameplay by Bank Monsieur he dealt with
all these opening problems he has good
control of the d4 square for the moment
and now he just goes about trading off
his bad pieces for White's active pieces
and improving his own pieces in the
process Fabi opted for Bishop e3 trying
to keep this Bishop on the board and now
the move g6 by black is a nice one to
solidify this Knight leave this Bishop
open for the moment and leave these
ideas of Knight takes g3 and Knight f4
alive for the moment
riki one is supporting the e pawn still
just preparing this d4 break by Fabi but
really he has achieved nothing out of
this opening and we do see Knight takes
g3 pawn takes g3 and now black can even
just play moves like King g7 and this is
kind of the power of Magnus's opening
choice here it looks awfully awfully
risky to be going for so much with both
c5 and e 5 having to draw this Bishop
out to d6 but this is what it looks like
when it goes well Magnus has absolutely
no problems out of this opening he's
going to have a very active play on the
Queen side now and we'll see that this
just turns in to a win for him so this
should have more or less been a word of
warning for fabi's seeing how well
magnus actually used the slightly
unorthodox system to his advantage and
we'll definitely see that he does
improve on it in the next couple games
in the meantime let's see how this game
wrapped up I say wrapped up there's
quite a lot of chests left to be played
but as far as our openings class is
concerned that if one was played and
then aged 593 Bobby's rerouting trying
to make use of the d5 weakness now h4
Magnus does not give a care for what
Bobby's doing in the center
just expanding on the Kings side we have
takes takes now g3 by father Bishop back
to g5 and we do see this trade and now
after Queen f3 I'll ask you guys at home
to try and find the key move here for
black this is kind of a natural
continuation of blacks plans so far he
closed down the center with his opening
play with c5 and e5 and then he expanded
on the Kings side with h5 h4 and taking
on h4 and so what is the follow up now
how does black continue this King side
attack what do you guys think yeah and
the YouTube chat already has it
man ELP and Denny Ortiz both with the
move
f5 this is the move played in the game
and it is I think the best move for
Magnus the most logical continuation of
the play f5 just continuing to open
things up using this nice active Queen
over here using our nice bishop where as
this bishop on c4 now starts to look a
little bit out of place there's this
term for bishops where when they're
staring at really really solid pawns
they're biting on granite you know for
example like a bishop on a 3 would be
biting on granite right can't get past
the c5 pawn this bishop on c4 sort of
has the opposite problem where it's it's
biting on on thin air right you know
nothing to really chomp down on here
whether it's rock or you know even a
king nothing really doing for this
bishop and that's why that that's why
white is really just not doing very well
here black has laid all the space and
the better pieces we see it takes f5 now
Bishop takes that 59.5 rook f5 Queen g2
Rick a f8 rookie to rookie rook a to e1
and then I don't want to spoil anything
for the tactics class coming up here
because Magnus does play a very very
nice move to continue the attack here
but jumping ahead we did see Magnus
break through and go up the exchange and
go on to win this game if you want to
see the killer tactic
for the next class because we're also
going to be going over the key tactics
from this match and of course Magnus
wins this endgame with a little bit of
difficulty
so to recap this game the story was
Magnus going for the early c5 to control
d4 Fabi unable to punish the awkward
placement of this Bishop allowed black
to develop naturally and because of that
black got a very comfortable position
and managed to convert it into a win
because he is the world champion and
that's just what he does also nice idea
by black that you should probably keep
in mind this idea of nine age 5 just to
resolve this tension between these
bishops and to get this night to a nice
active square where it can look at
squares like f4 okay moving on to game 2
meaning I think not game 2 but game 9 I
believe in the match if I'm getting it
correctly I think ah Ben Simon claims
the last game was game 9 I don't know
then alright in this game things went a
little bit differently
we have Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop e5 c5
castles Bishop d6 so far everything is
exactly the same now in the previous
position Fabi essayed the move d3 and
here
Magnus replied with the move Knight f6
and this turned out to be a little bit
of a problem for Fabi you know not a
problem in the classical sense where
it's threatening something but just
because black is able to develop two
natural squares and has this extra
positional boon to to boot with this
pone on c5 so I'll challenge you guys at
home to find the opening subtlety here
what move can you play here to make
Knight f6 look a little bit less
appealing what move can you play to make
Knight f6 seem a little bit worse than
normal and I'll give you a brief brief
hint here it takes advantage of this
bishop on d6 and this is why I think
this is the best move in the positions
why fabi's switched to it or at least
switched back to it depending on the the
game order here any chance these classes
could be a little bit earlier well sorry
to hear that
ex row you can't always watch the vod's
but I guess it's kind of a remnant of
bygone eras we have the classes kind of
in the evening here because when the
club is open we do want people to come
attend in person and we want to give
them some time
you know after 5:00 p.m. after they get
off work to come out and come down to
the club we are you know kind of
foremost a chess club and then we do
like writing you guys with all this
online entertainment but that's kind of
why we have all these classes sort of at
the same time every night okay there's
some ideas in the chat though the move
c3 is being mentioned move h3 and g4 is
being mentioned with some pretty direct
threats to the knight c4 even got a
mention and the move Knight a3 is also
getting mentioned 93 is a really
interesting one I'm not certain it
actually prevents the move Knight f6
though I think we might still be able to
get away with this move and now because
you brought your night out here it's
true you can come to c4 and challenge my
pieces but you are sort of leaving this
guy behind for a moment so you can
imagine something like this and hold on
let's see where this bishop goes I think
yeah just back to c7 you can get a funny
line like this but at the end of the day
you are going to have to defend this guy
and you get some sort of Russell emote
type positions or you do in fact
actually have this trade of the bishop
for the knight on c6 it's certainly one
way of playing it's not a bad way of
playing it's not what I had in mind here
though specifically I wanted to
discourage the move Knight f6 and while
g4 g5 might you know discourage Knight
f6 I don't think we want to be doing
this to our King side so the move is in
fact going to be the move c3 and at
first it's not entirely obvious you know
what's
a connection between the move c3 and the
move Knight f6 and especially this
bishop on d6 well the point is everybody
knows the tactic where a pawn Forks to
pieces by moving up in the center and
attacking them at the same time and the
idea here is is simply no different if
you play the move Knight f6 you're gonna
get met with the move d4 and if you're
not careful you have no good way to kind
of solve this issue on the e5 square I
don't even think we need to include the
move Bishop takes c6 just C takes d4
immediately and this move D takes e5 is
going to be coming with authority and
this is really what Black has to look
out for there's no time to castle as you
will now be met with this move and now
here would be winning a piece if you try
to take on e4 well look out because you
know the downside did not castling is
that you do leave your King in the
center indeed take c5 is gonna be a
powerful move so this is the opening
subtlety that really changes the story
here with c3 we can now ensure the Black
Knight it's not going to be quite so
happy coming to this f6 square and for
that reason we do actually see the
world-champion play the move first a six
bishop back to a 4 B 5 bishop back to C
2 and now the move Knight G to e7 if
Knight to f6 here well you're facing the
same issues of d4 it's still coming this
Bishop not totally necessary for these
tactics to sort of make some waves here
for example castles takes we wouldn't be
winning a piece here anymore but due to
the awkward placement of this Bishop
winning the bishop pair would be very
very comfortable now for white
especially with the wide open center so
97 instead and now Bobby goes back to
his old ways just plays the move d3 and
prepares to develop naturally in the
game we do see Knight g6
from the world champion and oh my
goodness I'm mixing up my games here but
no need to worry because I think 96 is
novelty in this game so I'm going to
drive Bensimon crazy and switch games
really quickly here d3 we had this
position this is the game I wanted to
look at and in this game ya know it's
the same position which is why I got it
confused but I think this is the earlier
game in this game Magnus Carlsen played
castles Bobby develops naturally with
Bishop III and Magnus plays Bishop e7
and we'll see why in a moment and the
other game the world champion switched
to 96 so here I want you to find Bobby's
next move it's a pretty nice idea by
white it shows you where white wants to
be playing on the board what white wants
to be doing so go ahead take a moment
here and try and find white's idea looks
like a roy lopez note yeah this line
does transpose into a lot of roy lopez
lines like i was saying that key
differences are the placement of these
two pieces and now thanks to fabi's
slightly more accurate move order the
difference is also this night being on
e7 rather than f6 so i see a lot of one
moves being suggested and the right move
i believe is already in the chat but try
and take a second and figure out what
you want to do with the rest of your
pieces as well specifically look at
these two pieces and think to yourself
what new options are available to me
with these two pieces being slightly
misplaced
so a lot of people are there's seems to
be sort of a four-way split one part of
the camp wants to play the move 92 and
I'm not going to tell you that this is a
bad move it's perfectly reasonable move
but it's perhaps missing the opportunity
that Magnus is allowed here the move a 4
I think is is pretty common for these
Spanish positions trying to break down
this b5 pawn but it's not really gonna
be our idea here you know playing on the
Queen side doesn't really make use of of
these pieces being out of the way here
so of course the correct move is the
muthaf late in the game
it's a move being suggested quite a lot
it's the move Knight h4 Knight h4 is a
really really great idea here for white
and it really does make use of the
awkward placement of blacks pieces and
this is the idea that I want you guys to
try and take away and use in your own
games hopefully if you do find yourself
playing against something very very
similar to an opening very similar to
the Royal apes' in this case but with
some pieces slightly differently placed
be sure to look at those differences and
see what new options are available to
you that's really a great way to
navigate both openings and middlegame
positions it's all about relating what
you see on the board to what you already
know so you say ok with the knight on f6
and the bishop on e7 you know these
pieces are well placed the bishop does a
good job of controlling these dark
squares this knight in the meanwhile it
controls g4 and h5 so with these pieces
sort of lacking now we can play Knight
h4 a lot more easily and in fact we can
even bring this Queen out to g4 and this
is the key move that nobody in the chat
really mentioned to my knowledge but
this is a really key idea here in my
opinion for white the lack of the knight
on f6 is a really really important
defender that's just not there and
that's why Fabi it's a good position in
this
and gets a good attack and does manage
to convert it so in the game
Magnus played Ricky ate Bobby does take
the time out of his day to play ninety
two and now we do seen IG six come on
the board but it's a little too late now
as soon as the night vacates the f5
square our knight is ready to jump in
and we see Bishop f8 and now this move
between g4 does finally come on the
board and this is just a hugely pleasant
position now for white and this is the
the main point of the lecture here
tonight it's one just to enjoy these
openings played but this I believe is
the most instructive point making use of
the differences in positions from what
you already know you know where these
pieces belong in the Royal apes' you
know where they normally go and now you
see well wait these pieces look slightly
different and then you can take
advantage of it as Fabi does here and
this is the killer opening play that
gives Fabi an advantage in this game d6
and now I'm sure everybody at home
already knows the next couple moves that
are coming on the board well at least
then the next one is the move everybody
wants to play in this position of course
I'm talking about the move Age 4 you go
after this night on g6 and go after the
King if you ever see a knight planted on
g6 and it's in the way of your attack h4
h5 that's almost always the way to go
to get rid of this Knight and we do have
King h8 now from the world champion of
course h4 did make a threat does anybody
see the threat if let's say black just
passes here this plays like rook b8
who sees the threat who sees the threat
do you guys see it at home what you got
all right I'm just gonna reveal it don't
wanna spend too much time here on
tactics we of course would play h5 and
then Knight h6 check Knight takes f7
check and that is gonna be a winner for
white so of course
Magnus doesn't allow this place King h8
now if a knight lanes on aged six it
will in fact be captured so Bishop b3 is
a really great move by Fabi switching
diagonals back to b3 and challenging
this pawn on f7 now that it's only
defender has left black plays Queen c7
and from here it's just a master class
in attacking from Fabiano Knight f3
bringing more pieces into the attack
Knight a5 we do just see Bishop d5 now
by Fabi Bishop takes d5 pawn takes d5 f6
now h5 is removing this Knight 97 Knight
takes c7 Queen takes e79 h4 we have
queen up to f7 c4 by white takes takes
now efore by black and for those of you
who may have already seen the games live
Magnus did actually miss an opportunity
to get back into the game which I'm
going to talk about in tactics class but
it doesn't really have much to do with
the opening play so b3 by white now
defends on c4 King g8 and fish it back
to d2 and the story really is just that
all of these pieces are bad and these
pieces are good and Fabi does win the
game from here 97 Bishop c3 rookie 5
Magnus felt the need to sacrifice in
exchange and from here it is just a
technically winning position for Fabi
takes takes and there was some practical
difficulty took Bobby a little bit
maneuvering around but he does come up
with this nice b4 idea to break the
blockade on these dark squares breaking
through onto the e5 square and from here
he does manage to convert d7 d8 and that
is an extra queen for Fabiano so the
difference here in this game from game
one
see three this is the really really key
move defending the d4 square and now
with this very much discouraging move
Knight f6 due to this nice idea of d4 so
this brings the knight to e7 instead and
now d3 and met Bobby makes use of this
misplaced night now I know Ben said this
one was game 11 but I am almost entirely
sure that's not quite accurate because
I'm a hundred percent certain that this
game was game 11 but well sort this one
out so in this last game I want to look
at today this I I'm really sure on this
one was game 11 of the match the
penultimate round Fabiano was in almost
a must-win situation he was down one
point going into these last two rounds
which were both worth three points due
to the format of the tournament so with
a win here he would be in a very very
good spot to win the match and so what
did he pull out the same stuff he had
been playing efore c5 and we get in
identical position accepts this got
messed up just a bit okay when we get an
identical position with c3 a six Bishop
back b5 and Bishop back GE 7 now d3 from
Fabiano and you know Magnus Fulham once
but tough to fool him twice he can't get
fooled again as a certain president
would say Knight g6 and this was
Magnussen's big improvement on the
previous position now not allowing white
to play this nice move Knight h4 get
this kind of bind on the Kings side get
these pieces activated really really
quickly
instead playing an early early night g6
and going for the a slightly more
restrictive approach on the Kings side
rather than just ignoring it and playing
these developing moves like castles in
Bishop d7 immediately in the game Bobby
just develops with the move Bishop e3
Knight bTW - now Bishop e7 and Fabi does
something really really interesting here
so black of course took a very
conservative approach to the Kings side
after the fiasco that happened in that
last game that we looked at so not as
easy to kind of contest this Kings side
here for white so with that in mind what
do you guys think Bobbie should do here
should he still try and push through on
the Kings side using a different you
know maneuver should each tried to
switch to the to the Queen side should
he try to switch to the center and how
should he go about doing these things
let me know what you guys think here in
the chat
a couple fans of the move a four there's
one fan of the move Knight b3 which does
make a threat rook e1 Knight f1 and the
g3 is a maneuver that's been suggested
aiming for this F 5 square H 3 d 4 so
some good ideas here these are all kind
of classical roy lopez you know ideas
plans in positions like these however
I'm going to ask you once again to fall
back on this method I was talking about
in the previous game Bobby came up with
the move Knight age 4 and Queen g4 and
at least my thought process following
these moves as you look at the
difference of the pieces and then try it
to take advantage of it but now you know
we know a little bit about the position
that we just had this is now game 11 you
know we have this knowledge banked and
what's the difference in this position
compared to the last position well Black
has spent two full tempi on the Kings
side rather than spending these tempi
developing elsewhere and because black
has spent these tempi on the Kings side
it does make sense that he's less
equipped to deal with threats in the
center right this bishops not yet on the
b7 square this bishop has dropped back
no longer defending e5 this Knight has
also left the defense of the d5 square
and so the center is now where Fabi
decides to make his break and that's a
really really sensible approach it all
comes back to relating these positions
to what you already know and from there
as you play more and more games play
more positions in these openings you
start to really understand more and more
ideas and become better equipped to
handle these sort of curveballs that
inevitably get thrown at you right
nobody always gets a game in their prep
but this is how you can start to develop
that really solid knowledge base and be
able to handle differences in the
winning so here Fabi first decided to
focus on this d5 square this night of
course leaving the d5 square the bishop
not yet on b7 he plays the move Bishop
b3 and it's a really interesting
maneuver here by Fabi bringing the
bishop back out and now aiming for the
d5 square he's made it very very
difficult
well Magnus has made it very very
difficult for himself to get back to a
square on e7 with a knight so it's
difficult to challenge a bishop landing
on d5
so after t6 we do in fact see the move
Bishop d5 with threats along this
diagonal Magnus came up with the move
Queen e8 and now I'm sure you guys at
home know the follow up here for Fabi
this is the key break in the position
making use of the fact that the black
pieces have sort of evacuated the center
just a little bit
so here of course the move is d4
breaking in the center and I can't
stress it enough you can come up with
these ideas by relating positions to
positions we've already seen positions
you've already known and this is another
reason why it's so critical to analyze
your games after you play them your your
tournament games at the very least
because if you analyze them and
understand what happened in the opening
then you do increase your sort of
knowledge base you get to understand
more and more and more and be able to
handle these types of positions but ok
so d4 is the big break making use of the
fact that the black pieces are sort of
underdeveloped comparatively right
you're used to seeing these positions
with like a rook on ei maybe the bishop
back on f8 this knight on f6 that's push
it back on c2 you know if those four
things were all different then maybe
this would be just a dead equal position
for black or maybe black would be I
don't I'm trying to play for an
advantage somehow I I doubt it but those
four things aren't kind of missing right
and those are definitely worse changes
for black and then better so e takes d4
now we have C takes d4 rook b8 and now
rook to c1 by Bobby and I think Bobby at
this point does just have a pleasant
position now I don't think Magnus has
done things really really terribly wrong
yet so I don't think black is like
losing or anything in that first game
things did sort of go very wrong very
fast for him but here there's there's
still a chess game to be played but I
definitely would prefer the white
position with the strong bishop on d5
this extra central control and this now
active rook on the C 1 square so the
game continued with night before trying
of course to get rid of this Bishop and
Fabi takes this opportunity to capture
on c5 and after takes sorry it takes
here first
Bishop takes Knight takes d5 ET takes d5
and rook takes
Bishop takes rook takes for the moment
Fabiano is just up a clean deep on
Magnus felt that his position was bad
enough that he needed to just get rid of
this Bishop at all costs sacrificing the
c5 pawn and Fabi does now have a a
pretty good position and goes on to win
this game Bishop e7 this net comes to b3
supporting this rook and supporting this
pawn queen D 795 be a knight c6 rook B
to e8 Knight FD for Queen d6 b4 and this
is just dead busted for black skipping
ahead here don't want to spend too much
time we do see that
Fabi eventually wins this game with some
nice sacrifices here Knight takes EA
rook back to e7 with the pin but we just
sacrificed the Queen now roof takes b7
and then as I was watching this game
life I really really really wanted
Fabiana to play Knight f6 because I
thought it looked cool but this move
doesn't even win because there's an
escape square for the King so he plays
the much better move with night e to d6
which does win with these threats to the
Queen now play move like Queen f6 or c8
check King h7 and white has two knights
and a rook for the Queen which is more
than enough
so Fabi did manage to win game 11 but
you know I was watching in the chat room
actually of the clutch chess broadcast
to see what they were all doing in there
and there seem to be a lot of
accusations that this channel is biased
towards Fabiana I don't know where that
came from
maybe they saw that we printed team Fabi
shirts when he was in the World
Championship maybe that gave them the
idea but I don't know but enough of this
Fabi bias let's take a look at some
games played by the world champion with
the white pieces now that kind of wraps
up that Roya Lopez or weird Sicilian
openings and now we're gonna take a look
at Magnus Carlsen with the white pieces
playing actually the ink
with some slightly offbeat lines so
jumping into that we have to move c4 c5
Knight c3 Knight f6 g3 Bishop b4 and so
this is a pretty interesting approach to
the English particularly because of
Magnus's next move it may look slightly
familiar to you who just saw the last
three games he plays the movie 4 of
course you know this move does seem to
break the same principles that we talked
about in the previous games and it is
sort of a reversed position of that
opening line that we talked about the
difference here is that the character of
this position is going to be totally
totally different you do have some
reverse positions that maintain sort of
the same ideas that's not really gonna
be the case here in this case because
white does have this extra tempo black
does have to play a lot more
conservatively than we saw Fabiana
playing when you had this sort of what
the colors reversed playing you know the
white side of these kinds of well still
playing you know the black side of this
but with the extra tempo because he had
the white pieces so in this case Fabiana
just shops off on c3 we see B takes c3
and now not Knight takes e4 again as the
move Queen e2 here would be enough to
regain the pawn for example f5 would
start to get a little bit silly with
Knight f6 Knight takes Queen takes e5
and this is not really something that
that black wants to go for you could get
some type of endgame but these are gonna
be favorable for white with the bishop
pair so not 9 takes e4 rather just
castles by black and now Magnus plays
the move f3 which honestly is is not the
greatest move in all of chess of course
you know f3 is a good supporting move
towards the center you know we do talk
about supporting the center quite often
but in these positions I do think it
makes just more sense to continue
developing naturally with a move like
this should g2 and this is very very
well known Tara
actually this night come out to eat ooh
now supporting the center it's a little
bit of a different story with this night
coming to e2 rather than f3 here here it
happens by choice because we don't want
to block off our own Bishop and y can
just expand in the center in the near
future
no I move like d5 is likely on blacks
mind and you sort of just get everything
blowing up here and this is pretty well
known territory but rather than go for
the norm Magnus and decided to shock
everyone first with the move f3 now
black responds with the move rook to e8
and this is a another really instructive
move by it
Fabiano I want to say and the reason for
that is he's following the same
principle that I talked about earlier
you know he knows this line with Bishop
g2 I guarantee he knows it because he's
just the greatest ever or at least
second greatest ever and what's the
difference between Bishop g2 and f3 or
Fabiano spots it White's not developing
his pieces in time his king could get
stuck in the center thus the move rook
e8 preparing to open up lines to get at
this King now what happens if white
plays sort of nonchalantly well if you
play the move d4 you're already starting
to ask for a little bit of trouble with
opening up these files in the center I
don't think though black actually does
want to capture probably just a move
like d6 and we are solidifying here and
you do have to look out for the e-file
opening so instead though Magnus of
course played the move King f2 shocking
the world in this game now if AB you
know plays pretty reasonably with c6 we
have d4 by White's and now Fabi actually
goes for the maximum tension in the
center with the move d5 and the move
rook e8 again coming in in handy here
supporting this e5 pawn
well black expands in the center and
this is one of those cases where white
has done enough wrong that he's never
really going to be pressing for an edge
in this particular position in the game
see text e5 happened C takes D 5 D takes
d5 or it takes C 5 C 4 and now this does
actually pose one or two problems to
black here because his pieces are very
very temporarily disorganized you know
this Queen is loose on d8 this rook is
loose on e5 you do get met with this
awkward question of what you're doing
with this pawn there is actually a way
it turns out for Fabi to solve this idea
you had to find the move Queen b6 check
when after Bishop to e3 you have to
attack this queen with tempo otherwise
we're happy to sort of trade this guy
off I think on e4 rather than c4 but now
Queen B to check and after the block
Fabi is going to be happy to capture
here and it turns out this tactic just
doesn't quite work because of some
counter punches on the Kings side
example Bishop takes e5 Queen takes f3
King g1 queen III check and this would
have been a level way for in the game to
end understandably Bobbie didn't see
that far in this rapid game said he
played d4 in less than 10 seconds
d4 of course is the other option here
just preserving this pawn and now Magnus
does actually have a claim to some kind
of an edge here and that's just down to
Fabi perhaps rushing a bit with this
break d5
this is actually the only line that
really justifies d5 if you see this
unpinning technique with the Queen
instead rather if Fabi had played the
move d6 just taking a slightly slower
approach then black would be doing
absolutely fine here just for example if
I don't know some sensible move like
Bishop d3 gets played well Bishop d3
would allow d5 because now we don't have
this
but also just simple development here 92
and we are gonna break with d5 once we
get just a bit more developed because
this pin on the D file was really the
only thing stopping us from from doing
that so in the game though Bobby played
d5 got himself in a little bit of
trouble with this pawn on d4 and let's
talk about why that is
well this pawn on d4 is technically a
passed pawn the issue is it's more of a
weakness than a benefit with all of
these pieces on the board it's not so
easy to keep this guy super well
defended and then the meanwhile it is
going to be pretty easy for white to
attack this pawn for 1 blockade this
pawn for 2 and play around this pawn
it's not like this pawn is taking away
critical squares from the white pieces
so in the game 92 was played already
attacking the sky knight c6 now Knight
f4 eyes two really key squares this
knight actually dropped back to d7 in
the game and then we saw 95 by Magnus
and this is more or less you know
White's claim to an advantage here he
claims he gets the strong knight on d5
which is unassailable by any of the
black pawns and black is definitely not
able to do the same on the d4 square
okay so rookie was played in the game
and now Bishop at 4 and white got some
nice activity we saw Knight d2 e5 we get
a trade of the bishop for the Knights
now fish is out to d3 blockading the
pawn and f5 was fabi's try to create
some counter play we saw rook e1 I have
take C for Bishop takes e4 Bishop f5
takes takes F for Queen d7 rook b1 rook
a to f8 Bobby eyeing and this f4 guy but
this is really just gonna be a a good
position for Magnus here King g2 or
sorry kim ji-won played in the game f7
and I am going to play these through
these moves rather quickly as this is a
little bit outside the scope of this
openings lecture
Magnus pushes on the kingside eventually
but does not manage to actually get
enough queens come off the board
see these guys get traded and this end
game may be winning but that is a
question for the end game class this is
not the end game class this is the
opening class and out of nowhere
Magnus suddenly hung all of his pawns
and the game was drawn in pretty severe
time pressure so that was their first
foray into this English with kind of the
reversed idea from those first three
games we looked at and then I wanted to
take a look at the second game and this
is actually the final game of the entire
match and this is where it was all
decided just some context for you going
into this game
Fabiano as we saw in this last game has
faced this system from Magnus before and
the current match situation was Fabiana
was had a decisive lead and Magnus was
in a must-win situation
Magnus drew or lost Fabi wins the match
if Magnus wins this game and then Magnus
wins the match they were in a pretty
unique situation where you know what a
tie was impossible you know they
couldn't tie the match anymore but both
players could still win so Magnus much
win situation
Fabiano a draw is enough to clinch and
Magnus comes right back out with the
move c4 this is game 12 E 5 Knight c3
and Knight of 6 and g3 Bishop b4 and E
for the exact same thing we just saw
Fabi plays the move - Bishop takes c3 B
takes c3 black went ahead and castled we
did see f3 as in the previous game and
then Fabi had a unique idea sort of in
store for Magnus in
this case so in the previous game we saw
the move rook e8 in Fabi got into a fine
position but after d5 did find himself
running into a bit of trouble
so perhaps you know he went back home
and saw that after it there are more
options than just king f2 and honestly I
would be surprised to see Magnus repeat
the move King f2 so it sort of makes
sense that Fabi wanted to come up with
something new here not wanting to no
allow his opponent to deviate first
so rather than rook e8 father comes up
with the move b5 and this at first is a
bit of a stunner
you know be fob definitely is not the
first move that crosses your mind and
the idea though is fairly logical right
in the previous game we saw Fabi
struggling to get the move D get the
move d5 to work you know he ran into
this issue of this move C for an issue
he wasn't able to really adequately
solve found himself in a little bit of
trouble so using that as a jumping-off
point
it's not so ridiculous to come up with
the move b5 relating and learning from
previous games that's what these top
players do in these matches so b5 in the
idea of course is if you do capture this
pawn you're gonna get met immediately
with the move d5 and you don't have time
for any of your funny business with d4
and potential pins along the D file and
while this is a pawn sacrifice it is a
pretty comfortable one for Fabi you can
follow it up with a move like a 6 for
example takes Knight takes and as we get
developed here Bishop e3 for example
Queen e7 Fabi just enjoys a nice lead in
the center and has some quick
development in return for the pawn to
continuing the line just a bit Knight h3
for example d4 is creating immediate
threats if you capture this guy Queen
before check so Bishop back to D two
knights c5 and you can see it's just
very comfortable to play now
with the black pieces and this is likely
what Fabi was kind of looking forward to
playing in the game though
Magnus did not accept the pawn instead
going for d4 immediately and now of
course you're running do very very
similar problems if you still go for
this d5 business in the game
Fabi came up with a takes d4 C takes d4
b takes e4 and now II five and all of a
sudden here I very much am unsure if
Fabi was totally totally comfortable in
this position he gave an interesting
post game interview we'll post match
interview actually and he more or less
said yeah he looked at it he saw this b5
move it was a good move and he thought
that was just gonna be the end of the
story but this is really a wildly
imbalanced position here white of course
with all of his pieces stuff sitting on
the back rank but very very very solid
control of the center and that's the
story in this game so what were some
other options for black here well you
could in a sense kind of just double
down play rook e8 and say you you are
going to want to capture my c5 pawn and
then still go in for these types of
positions here but you know honestly I
think this move b5 is just asking for a
little bit of trouble it might be that
black isn't any worse in this position
but I think it's pretty indisputable
that black is it's not quite as
comfortable as white Bishop takes c4
challenges this Knight Bishop b7 now by
a be developing and defending Knight h3
is actually the natural developing move
in this case don't really want to come
to e2 and block all your pieces so
Knight h3 challenges the g5 square you
can come back to f2 and E 4 as well can
you even jump into f4 in some cases now
the move d6 is pretty natural by Fabi
you don't see strong players let these d
4e 5 sort of pawn shortages exist for
too long they are going to challenge
them
and probably challenges it as quickly as
possible with this king still in the
center
castles now by Magnus in 87 rook e1 and
after D takes e5 D takes e5 Knight 7 to
b6 Bishop back to b3 between e7 and in
this position
Magnus came up with a very very strong
move which I guess I'm going to spoil
here if you're watching the tactics
class next this will make a brief
reappearance at the end but white to
move and get a very very good position
here it is of course going to be the
move plate in the game isa 'kz the fact
of the matter is when you give up so
much central space like Fabi did in this
game you are very much asking for
trouble and you have to be on the
lookout through these types of
sacrifices these types of moves on every
turn perhaps I don't know maybe slightly
better for Fabi was to play the move c5
the idea being now if you go for similar
stuff we can just take and we are just
in time to lock in this Bishop out of
the game before things get get too crazy
here in the game though
Queen e7 was not going to be enough ye6
comes on the board F takes a six and now
Knight g5 and white is quite simply
crushing in this position f6 Queen c2
rook g6 and then more tactics to follow
lead to the end of the game pretty
quickly here with Magnus just going up a
queen and finishing Fabi off here so
once again I really enjoyed looking at
these openings in the clutch chess match
up and if there's any lesson to take
away from this it's that there really is
usefulness and analyzing your games and
a lot of that usefulness
does come in these opening positions you
take the ideas that you found in your
games you take a look at whether or not
they were actually good well they're not
there
working you try to understand why look
at the differences from things you
already know and with time you start to
kind of grow that knowledge base you
start to become a better player you
start to just know these things from the
top of your head if Magnus and Bobbie
are still doing it at their level
definitely there's still things we can
learn at you know our lowly amateur
level as well that is it for chess
openings explained tonight thank you
guys so much for joining me if you want
to stick around we are going to be doing
a tactics class live on Twitch right
after this if not thank you guys once
again for joining me my name is Caleb
Denby and I will see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you